okay em next game with the International
Master from Russia meat-eor 80-84 the
sloth I had pretty good results with
them exchange variation so let's try
this again oh it's offering a troll no I
don't play this to make it raw really
peace queen bee six no idea that's so
yes
no idea of the screen intermezzo really
did anything good for blacks position
the night is not so bad on a four
because c5 is always on a sub target
square okay
I want to keep the bishop ok see you i
texted with g5 I need the square to
ok
kiss
looks aggressive at least what is he
playing for f4 no idea if I've hard to
play for ok ok the some blunts my bishop
but everything else is pretty much ok
a night on c5 is some hindering blacks
development another idea also could be
to drop the night back to d3 in order to
put some pressure on a form ok he wants
to go to juice exit it seems yeah maybe
get the King out of the way that after
Queen g6 Bishop h3 is intermediate
threat
okay i go now to d3 might take on d4 of
course
why do I take on a six-play be five next
smooth
could be interesting not sure ideas to
have the fork here and be five
okay now be five I'll take first
interesting yeah they take first and
then be five ok now it's the question if
it takes you taking with the rook or
taking with them the pawn takes with the
pawn I take with the pond maybe he has
gotten I'd see three then
let's take a look
93 then just 23 I think
very difficult position do I want to
play Bishop g one who came it's not a
move you really want to play still I
don't see how to cover f2 decently but
still be six is hanging and maybe I
threaten night peace queen bee three
ok
it's not really convenient to this
position come up be five
yeah of course I've got a really awful
bishop here
not sure how I could activate this piece
maybe night age 42 nite 96 done and
Queen f3 to activate down
you
time were nearly complicated
get the Queen over d-force hanging but
i'm not sure if this is the real problem
I didn't see that one thing okay okay
capture them
see if I've got some attack here this
was a really weird game just play badly
thing
I don't I don't even have a threat here
so this can play pretty much anything
yeah it's unfortunately it's too much
material eyes got to check now doesn't
go for it like it doesn't matter white
boy hits on time yeah I really I really
lost the thread here in this position
this really should should be okay yeah
of course 92 I cannot allow this of
course
very difficult do a quick good check
calm just wants to play Roxy one and
gives white + 1.5 plus 2 now yeah it
should be good for white somehow but no
was complicated too complicated for me
to take I think